have a lesion still left in my hip, but all else is clear.
Oh, these both philexical, didn't they?
They may do low dose radiation as with my glove counts
cannot do any more chemo for now.
What do you think about that?
Well, partly depends on where it is in your hip, too.
So if it's at a weight-barried issue,
so there could be bone coverages and possible pathological
fracture that I would say for sure I would go
ahead with the radiation because the worst thing
that could happen is having a pathological fracture,
fracture on a weight-barried element of your bone.
So you don't want that.
But if it's not in a site that is going to be an issue with that,
there's lots of bones that are weight-barried per se.
And what you're saying, your pelvis is in the ilium
or the ishiium, those are weight-barried bones.
But if it's in the acetabulum, then you're
going to have a weight from the femur head that's going to be it.
So the iliac, the iliac crest area is where the lesion is.
Yeah, it just depends.
If it's a really small lesion, I mean,
you might want to just try to heal that naturally
and not do any more radiation.
So I do think radiation really shines
best when you're doing it to bone.
That's where you really see the best benefits.
But there isn't anything that is a without issue
when you're doing it, when you're radiation in your body.
If you're not having pain, it's not causing any issues.
I maybe would keep an eye on it.
So but you know, discuss it with the radiation
and the colleges, if they think just a few sessions,
it's going to knock it out because it's a real small spot.
Then I might reconsider that.